okay The O'Reilly Factor the bill
o'reilly program on fox news it has
offered us regularly racially
insensitive commentary over the years
there was the entire blacks are ill
educated with face tattoos forehead
tattoos there was bill o'reilly being
visibly shocked about going without
Sharpton to Sylvia's restaurant in
Harlem in Manhattan and being surprised
that black people weren't yelling out
give me more iced tea mother effer so
we've had a long history of just very
strange and insensitive comments from
Bill O'Reilly Jesse Watters is sort of
like a like a guy on the street type for
the Bill O'Reilly program every once in
a while he was sent to New York City's
Chinatown to talk to the people and
figure out how the people of Chinatown
are feeling about the upcoming election
and this is so cringeworthy and so
insensitive and so so uh sort sort of
prejudicial and stereotypical in the way
that people are portrayed you can tell
I'm gonna play some of this for you when
you if you're watching it if you listen
you won't be able to tell but when you
when you watch it you'll notice there
are people here being interviewed who
clearly don't even speak English and
Jesse Watters is sort of mocking their
silence because they don't speak your
language there are all sorts of just
insanely stereotypical comments like do
you know karate asked by Jesse Watters
this is indistinguishable from how
Saturday Night Live would parody an
insensitive and ridiculous Fox News
segment again Fox News and the American
right continuing to make Saturday Night
Live irrelevant let's take a look at the
video am I supposed to bow to say hello
hey oh hey hey look
I like these watches are they hot GTE
g98 do you like Donald Trump yes Hillary
Clinton basically is that a complete
extension of Obama are you going to vote
for Clinton wife Clinton's wife has a
name what is it old man
I'd forget it snap out of it what do you
think about Donald Trump
I don't like it Pearson has a big mouth
he can say what he wants it doesn't
really affect me and I don't think he's
gonna win so Trump has been beating up
on China how does that make you feel
yeah thanks why don't you speak Donald
Trump beating up on China at the debate
is it the year of the dragon rabbit well
who are you gonna vote for I really
don't want to vote for Trump so Hillary
so China can keep ripping us off I guess
yeah now Trump wants to build a wall to
keep the Mexicans out mm-hmm
square that circle I like Donald card
before I were to Cabrera jackpot
is everything made in China no not
everything tell me what's not made in
China I can't think of it right now
me neither I'm explaining to you because
you look nervous is China
America's friend or enemy China America
of course our friends can you guys take
care of North Korea for us wow that is
too much Yanks
I got frenemies frenemies do they call
Chinese food in China just food do you
have any traditional Chinese herbs for
performance oh I'm not going to ask my
parents about that I meant on television
oh okay okay where's our seat in that
sweep the leg
Gino karate yeah I know at my hand
that's not yet this went on for a couple
more minutes really hard-hitting news on
the Bill O'Reilly program the
asian-american Journalists Association
is de menthe demanded an apology saying
that people are being completely
humiliated and objectified targeted as
an ethnic group with stereotypes
etcetera etcetera I'm more offended by
the terrible humor than anything else
Bill O'Reilly admitted that there may be
some people out there who might be
offended by this but but Jesse Watters
reassured him later that it's all in
good fun
when did good fun turn into just mocking
an entire culture with the bassist and
silliest stereotypes this really is
representative of how many on the right
see other cultures or races or races or
whatever it's a caricature based on
kooky movie poor trails and media
stereotypes I don't know about you guys
I don't truly find this offensive as
much as I find it to be a waste of time
and just a cringe-worthy and
embarrassing programming decision by Fox
News it's reality television on a micro
scale because waters kind of specializes
in comforting conservatives making them
feel superior to his interview subjects
yeah he has a long track record
of doing this type of gongshow stuff and
this is probably the most outrageous one
that I remember uh and you know people
will write in and they'll say David oh
you're so sensitive and people are so
sensitive everybody's gotta stop being a
social justice warrior and just relax uh
that's not really what this is about
like I like I'm saying these are the
same stereotypes that are portrayed in
movies do you know karate the
stereotypical Chinese music and the
handpicking of mostly people who speak
with particular accents in English and
blah blah blah for me it's not so much
about being shocked by the offensive
nature
it's just that they're ridiculing
themselves by even stooping to this
level also could you imagine if he went
to like a predominantly black community
and made stereotypes against African
Americans and that would not even be
considered now that that would be I
think that's actually a really good
point which is this is only acceptable
with certain groups and with certain
stereotypes and if you imagine this
place in a different sort of scenario I
would still have right-wingers emailing
me saying oh David you're so sensitive
stop blah blah blah but it would
objectively speaking trigger an even
bigger response than this did just
absolutely insane let's take a break a
former Governor Martin O'Malley will
join me next